Marjorie Taylor green is weighing in on
the missing whistleblower or informant
who is fingering Joe Biden with crimes
as Larry Kudlow said she doesn't care
that there's no evidence she doesn't
care that The Whistleblower is missing
Marjorie Taylor green believes that the
Whistleblower will end the presidency
of President Joe Biden listen to this
other whistleblowers yes are missing
they're either in court
they're in jail or
found this is a very real situation it's
very real except there's no evidence and
the people making the claims are missing
but it's totally real talking about in
our investigation is so important Steve
um that this will bring down the
president of the United States and I
want to let everyone know something
we're going back to the treasury
Department today at one o'clock okay
because we have more financial records
that we have to review uh leading to the
Biden family and Joe Biden himself is it
possible that the whistleblowers were
evaporated by the Jewish space laser run
by Soros and Klaus Schwab or whoever is
in control of the thing you know they
should really put Mike pillow in charge
of the whole whistleblower thing if Mike
pillow were in charge it would just be
two more weeks until we get all of the
whistleblowers evidence and testimony
naturally of course it would be
perpetually two weeks until we got it
but at least it would be only two weeks
you know these people it it is funny
okay when you see Marjorie Taylor
Green's face and she she's pretending to
see her or maybe she is seriously saying
this whistleblower is going to be the
end of the presidency this is going to
be it for Joe Biden he's not going to be
able to survive this there is a funny
component I admit there's a funny
component but these are people who for
Generations have said we are the party
of Law and Order and yet forget about
evidence of crimes without even probable
cause without Reasonable articulable
Suspicion without a single document that
we might count as evidence without even
The Whistleblower The Whistleblower is
missing she can say with a straight face
this is going to be the the end of Joe
Biden's presidency and if it were up to
them they would have already removed
Biden despite the fact that Biden has
done nothing to make himself worthy of
removal from the office of the
presidency that's really the scary thing
and tens of millions of Americans at
minimum have fallen for it and they may
re-elect they may re-elect Marjorie
Taylor Green in 2024 they may put Trump
back in the White House in 2024 and so
the takeaway here is We cannot put our
guard down one of our sponsors is zipx
nicotine toothpicks don't you think it's
time you stopped putting smoke and vape
oils in your lungs zippix toothpicks are
a convenient way to curb the nicotine
Cravings zippix toothpicks are super
discreet you can use them anytime
anywhere smoking and vaping aren't
allowed including flights sporting
events in restaurants they're available
in six different flavors with options of
two and three milligrams of nicotine if
you're not a nicotine user zipix also
offers caffeine and b12 infused
toothpicks zipx has already helped tens
of thousands of customers ditch the
cigarettes ditch the Vapes they might be
able to help you too if you're a smoker
or a vapor give zipx toothpicks a try
your lungs will thank you go to
zipxtoothpix.com today save 10 with the
code pacman10 at checkout out just
remember you must be 21 or older to
order the link is down below